avec nous pourrons débattre sébastien
meurant sénateurs l ère du val d'oise
danielle simonnet conseillère de paris
oratrice de la france insoumise bonsoir
à tous les deux merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france le texte qui a
donc été réécrit un par les sénateurs
notamment ce fameux article 24 pour
créer un délit jossie de provocation à
d'identification et réprime et donc la
diffusion malveillantes d'image des
forces de l'ordre les républicains
étaient assez critique sur ce texte ce
qui vous satisfait désormais vous allez
le voter sébastien meurant de le voter
en l'état nous connaissons le biba
parlementaire il y aura beaucoup des
changes dans l'hémicycle et nous verrons
bien ce que va ce que vont donner ces
échanges les sept lois dites de sécurité
globale pourrait déjà se sature collé
sur le la de cette notion de sécurité
globale
c'est d'abord la preuve d'un échec
depuis que ce pouvoir est en place d'une
dégradation de la sécurité partout sur
le territoire et simplement en faisant
référence à deux remarques un but du
garde des sceaux je dupond moretti qui
entend parler de sentiment d'insécurité
et de l'autre pendant l'automne de
phases delà de la pièce c'est monsieur
darmanin qui fait le dur et qui en fait
traduisent ces de ces deux attitudes
traduisent les l'échec de ce
gouvernement sur la concorde et la paix
lorsqu'on parle de liberté
l'âge dans votre portage ni à des
militants qui se plaignaient de cette
loi mais la liberté elle est attaquée
depuis un an nous sommes en confinement
c'est quasiment jour pour jour nos
libertés je parle de toutes les libertés
donc là moi ce que je souhaite qu'ils se
dégage dans ce texte nyassa ne se réduit
pas à ça il ya des choses de bon sens
que lorsque j'ai g et émerge celle
locale lorsque vous allez pouvoir vidéo
verbaliser tout à sors de ta dah
civilité sur les dépôts sauvages lorsque
j'allais interdire l accès sécurité
privée à l'un des membres de personnes
qui sont radicalisées ou qui sont fichés
s c'est une bonne chose on tient
beaucoup d'amendements vous l'avez
signalé près de 350 ces amendements sont
faits pour être discutées pour être
amélioré mais avant tout cette loi dite
de sécurité globale est la preuve d'un
échec d'un gouvernement qui a subi qui a
laissé faire le saccage de l'arc de
triomphe
quelque chose de scandaleux qui n'était
jamais arrivé dans toute l'histoire de
france est par contre aussi et là on
peut peut-être se retrouver avec et bien
des pauvres gens qui lors de
manifestations ont subi il vient et des
actes de violence qui qu'ils aient eu
bien sûr sont tout à fait regrettable au
club l'objectif c'est de pouvoir
manifester en sécurité il faut penser
aussi que le droit de manifester est un
droit fondamental et le fait d'avoir un
drone au dessus de la tête
pour quelqu'un qui manifestent
visiblement ne devrait pas poser de
problème et la parole à daniel souben et
danielle simonnet vont vous faire réagir
journée vous faire écouter un autre avis
celui du président de la ligue des
droits de l'homme en région au moment où
antoine boutet côté ce qu'ils en pensent
de cette loi
cette loi qui est fait en procédure
accélérée ne règle pas tous les
problèmes
ce n'est pas d'une procédure accélérée
qu'on a besoin c'est d'un vrai débat sur
la sécurité car ça concerne tous les
citoyens pour qu'une loi soit équilibré
il faut aussi que les citoyens et des
outils de voies de recours pour pouvoir
dénoncer les abus d'une police qui
pourrait être de plus en plus
autoritaire et poser des problèmes on
voit danielle simonnet ça tourne
beaucoup autour des libertés publiques
et on entendu ces manifestants nous
parler voilà message d'impunité à la
police fait pour nous opprimer vous êtes
d'accord avec ce diagnostic des
opposants la loi oui parce qu'en fait
cette loi de sécurité globale en fait
elle organise une société de la
surveillance généralisée
en fait elle incarne vraiment toute la
dénier da la dérive répressive et
autoritaire autoritariste là on pourra
dire du gouvernement macro qui n'a
finalement plus qu'il ne tient plus que
par sa police alors il ya l'article 24
dont on parle beaucoup qui interdit le
fait de filmer les policiers on en parle
beaucoup pourquoi parce qu'il ya un an
notamment après l'assassinât enfin la
mort 2
de floyd aux états unis vous avez tout
un tas de mobilisation de manifestations
en france qu on permis de montrer que
beaucoup de bavures policières et bien
vécu être dénoncé un pavois justement le
fait que des vidéos avaient pu exister
mais il n'ya pas que cet article 24 qui
pose problème dans la loi sécurité
globale vous avez notamment l'article 22
par exemple qui organise la surveillance
par drones mais c'est pas simplement la
surveillance par drones sait que les
images prises par drones et bien par
exemple de manifestations sont associés
à de la reconnaissance faciale qui
montrent que finalement 1984 on est
dedans c'était on est vraiment dans une
société big brothers
il faut à faire attention c'est à dire
les nouvelles technologies ne sont pas
toutes bonnes à prendre voilà est
associée à ces politiques là c'est à sa
organise une privation liberté mais vous
avez également et c'est extrêmement
grave aussi dans la loi sécurité globale
en fait vous avez une une facilitation
et en vraie montée en compétences les
compétences des polices municipales et
des sociétés de sécurité privées et
finalement ce que s'organise
c'est le démantèlement de l'état la case
de la police nationale au profit de
sécurité privée et ça c'est extrêmement
inquiétant parce que nous avons besoin
d'une police républicaine qu'il faudrait
je pansse on refonde est complètement de
a à z d'ailleurs cette loi ne résout
absolument pas les problèmes terribles
de souffrance dans la police de
problèmes de sous-effectifs
vous l'avez dans la police par exemple
25 millions d'heures supplémentaires qui
n'ont pas été payés vous avez 60 % des
commissariats qui sont dans une vétusté
a terrible 56% par exemple du temps des
policiers et pris par le contrôle du
cannabis qui est une aberration faudrait
vraiment légaliser donc la loi ne pose
absolument pas la question des
conditions de travail de la police mais
par contre organise une privation de
liberté et on l'a bien vu venir ce
gouvernement ne cesse de tenter de
remettre en cause les libertés
fondamentales
on va bien sûr le la question on va vous
laisser le dialogué danielle simonnet
pardon c'est important ce que vous nous
dites mais essayer de dialoguer
peut-être entre vous et sébastien
meurant sur ces critiques apportées
danielle simonnet sur ces points précis
la liberté les drôles les nouvelles
technologies qui ne devrait pas être
remis à l'eau à ce service là en tout
cas à dire que la police bénéficie d'une
impunité en france et est une exactitude
c'est pas vrai la police et le 5 % des
fonctionnaires et le corps
fonctionnaires qui le plus contrôlé
remettez vos quarante ans en arrière à
la police était respectée c'est plus
qu'à maintenant donc il faut absolument
protéger nos forces de l'ordre parce que
vous n'aurez pas une société juste s'il
n'y a pas une société d'ordre il faut
effectivement que l'euro serait juste
mais là nous devons protéger nos forces
de l'ordre les porteurs d'uniforme les
pompiers les gendarmes les policiers
sont attaqué comme jamais et là c'est
inacceptable et le peut-être que la
façon dont ceux de ce gouvernement dans
ce président se comporte
peut-être effectivement je peux
rejoindre lorsqu'on parle de procédures
accélérées lorsqu'on parle de deux mois
de juin je suis un de ceux qui a voté
contre la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
considérant que les ordonnances
considérant que ce gouvernement faisait
passer faisait subir au parlement
quelque chose qui était anormal qu'ils
n'étaient pas conformes à l'esprit la
vème république qui pourtant une
république qui donne beaucoup de place à
l'exécutif donc sur ces plans là je peux
d'accord avec vous par contre vous
pouvez pas dire que la police bénéficie
d'une impunité vous ne pourriez vous pas
surtout comparé floyd et ce qui se passe
en france
venez c'est pas que dans un certain
nombre de coins de france des
territoires dits perdu des territoires
où l'être la population demande de
l'ordre de la sécurité il avoir un
public qui n'est plus à lui j'ai tous
présents aucunement écoutez monsieur ça
ne justifie aucunement que la police
puisse parfois hélas voilà avoir des des
actes répréhensibles or ce n'est pas le
seul on que je peux vraiment que les
politiques
non mais vous pouvez bien sûr que si ces
deux sujets une police républicaine
digne de ce nom
et bien que tu sais pas votre suzel ça
je me doute bien mais ça c'est notre
sujet pour nous les appelons souvent
qu'un pape dans ma tribu me laisser
faire une phrase quand même la solo les
cotations sont importants parce que
c'est la question du monopole de la
violence
physique légitime donc voilà exactement
et donc pour que ça puisse fonctionner
il faut absolument rétablir la confiance
du peuple en sa police et pour cela il
faut préserver et bien le droit à la
sûreté c'est à dire le fait que le
peuple savoir aussi un droit de contrôle
et de regard sur le fonctionnement de la
police voilà pourquoi par exemple nous
tenons énormément à la fois au droit de
pouvoir filmer les actions de police et
voilà aussi pourquoi nous ne sommes pas
du tout d'accord avec ce fonctionnement
de l'igpn qui dans la police finalement
être une machine à blanchir et il
faudrait au contraire une autorité par
des commandes ailleurs aux trois
fonctions publiques pour qu'il puisse
avoir sur les trois fonctions publiques
et bien un contrôle et des procédures de
contrôle administratif qui ne dépendent
pas des deux du même corps parce qu'on
voit bien très peu de policiers dans les
landes dans tout ce qui a pu se passer
par exemple manifestation gilet jaune
non de manifestants qui ont perdu un
oeil et borny par des tirs de l'est elle
bd ça n'est pas le rôle de la police
d'être le bras armé de l'état pour faire
passer l'ensemble de ses politiques
ces lois iniques et qu'il n'est pas
acceptable qui fait aussi des violences
policières des discriminations et donc
si on veut protéger la police
il faut absolument faire une réforme
profonde de fond en comble la police
pour en respecter une déontologie
irréprochable et c'est extrêmement
important mais il faut aussi le donner
les moyens humains à la police de pro à
faire un travail correct sur le terrain
or aujourd'hui on la met dans une
situation d'épuisement en lui demandant
par exemple toutes les opérations de
contrôle ouvre feu confinement parce que
ce gouvernement n'est pas n'est pas
capable de penser autrement que par la
logique de sébastien meurant pardonnez
moi pour faire avancer le débat
les syndicats de police sont peu
satisfaits de cette réécriture de la loi
par les sénateurs certains d'entre eux
comme sgp police nous disait tout
simplement cette loi était vidé de sa
substance et ne sert plus à rien
où êtes d'accord avec cette critique
formulée par les policiers parce que du
point non satisfait plus personne pour
certains va trop loin quand on écoute
madame simonet pour d'autres elles ne
servent plus à rien donc c'est dommage
vous savez les lois ne satisfont jamais
tout le monde
là c'est une certitude l'objectif c'est
trouver un équilibre
c'est de trouver une démesure et le
sénat la voix de la sagesse va essayer
ou au cours de ces discussions
effectivement vous la vie en procédure
accélérée de trouver un texte qui
correspondent à la fois aux attentes des
français parce qu'il faut quand même
partir des français et les français ils
ont une demande de paul si je ne demande
dans de tranquillité publique qui c'est
qui ce qui n'est pas le cas dans
beaucoup de territoires et bien sûr
certaines des aspects si madame sur
certains aspects sur tout un tas de
choses qui vous semble peut être bénigne
mais lorsque vous êtes élue locale
lorsque vous habitez devant des lieux
systématiquement soulier parce que vous
avez des dépôts sauvages lorsque vous
avez dit squat lorsque vous avez des
implantations de personnes sur les
véhicules soient des terrains privés
c'est bien là dessus ipalle dans les
trois mois qui ont suivi la police
nationale a réduit ses effectifs sur le
terrain donc vous allez bien que la
logique de ce gouvernement c'est de
casser l'état est de réduire le rôle de
la police républicaine nationale sur les
territoires au profit non seulement de
police municipale mais aussi de sociétés
de sécurité privées moi je suis très
inquiète par exemple par la question des
jeux olympiques de 2024 où vous allez
voir le nombre de sociétés de sécurité
privées à qui on va déléguer les tâches
de de sécurité de ces manifestations
là vous que là vous voyez on peut avoir
un un point d'accord et ont regretté
effectivement la privatisation d'une
partie de la sécurité des français
moi je suis un élu et à l'ail coûte des
citoyens français
et lorsque j'étais en responsabilité
j'ai effectivement subi la
réorganisation des services de l'état
sous monsieur hollande sous monsieur
macron avec la fermeture des
commissariats de quartier avec la
fermeture du policier
il ya dans ma commune et attend des
salles de classe et oui s'il vous plaît
on est pas du tout là je remonte pas
aussi loin parce que ce que vous dites
c'est exact c'est la police on en
n'était absolument pas à ce point de
thénac ans madame reconnaissez cela
narcoterrorisme nahman @ éclats les
théories marijuana sur quelques mets
dans mes vous mesdames là je crois que
vous faites erreur les le terrorisme la
lutte contre le terrorisme
s'il est agent des renseignements à qui
il faut donner les moyens humains c'est
pas de la police sur ce point lepreau
corps mais on sait que théorique selon
des services de renseignement avec des
moyens humains plus ou moins comme les
services en allemagne en tout cas ma
dernière question pardonnez moi parce
qu'on vous mettra pas d'accord sur ce
point danielle simonnet beaucoup de
critiques qui sont revenus en boucle ces
dernières heures c'est cette loi
finalement est beaucoup trop fou et
ouvre la porte à des abus c'est votre
avis aussi ça sera gros de la fin pour
chacun s'il vous plaît oui cette fois
m'inquiète énormément c'est pour ça que
nous continuons à la france a soumis à
demander le retrait total de la loi
sécurité globale parce qu'elle est
extrêmement liberticide et donc ça n'est
pas acceptable est trop floue pour vous
sébastien meurant il aurait fallu
davantage les préciser afin d'éviter les
abus que certaines craintes ou craignent
que certains craignent par dont 350
amendements des petites avancées aucune
vision globale de la chose c'est de la
communication encore une fois et
monsieur darmanin est un pion dans les
mains de monsieur macron qu'ils
utilisent pour faire et une politique de
communication à l'intention des forces
de l'ordre à l'intention d'une
population qui en demande d'ordre et par
rapport à ce qui a été dit avant n'y a
aucune il ya des déclarations
d'intention n'y a aucune volonté
d'assurer la sécurité des français
là c'est une loi en parle c'est un coup
d'épée dans l'eau effectivement en
procédure accélérée ce qui est important
quand même de noter c'est que nous avons
un temps extrêmement limité
pour amender cette loi et nous ferons de
notre mieux sachant très bien que cette
loi a une portée limitée mais amènera et
on votera sur le terrain des
améliorations et bien pour les français
et pour tous les français et aux
retraités c'est sûr que la police
républicaine n'est pas suffisamment de
moyens est normalement dans le code de
la procédure pénale c'est vraiment c'est
un palais de justice avant tout merci à
tous les jeunes
merci en tout cas d'avoir accepté ce
débat danielle simonnet merci à vous
donc ses basses oeuvres ont aussi
d'avoir été en direct avec nous sur rtl
france